ingrédients quantité et recettes ici on
calcule tout et on se prépare à cuisiner
c'est le concours des greta organisée
par les académies de versailles créteil
et paris
cette année la finale a lieu au lycée
hôtelier de guyancourt après l'étape
écrite d'une heure il faut passer en
cuisine mais je crois que devant les
fourneaux et remanié relais les
casseroles bien évidemment vous allez
pouvoir vous libérer et justement faire
preuve de tout le talent que l'on attend
de vous merci demandeurs d'emploi ou en
reconversion professionnelle
ils sont 22 stagiaires du réseau des
greta ile de france a tenté leur chance
pour se former dans la restauration
il ya de converser avec quelques années
et ça me passionne beaucoup
avant j'étais artiste peintre mais moi
je fais des bateaux je reste dans les
couleurs dans les matières vous avez
trente ans que je peux passer d'examen
et du coup une enfance et une pression
la pression naturelle de l'examen que je
sais qu'il ya un long jeu et rien à
perdre rien à gagner c'est comme ça
c'est naturel à peine le temps de
souffler direction les cuisines pour
karim
il doit réaliser deux plats en 3h30 mais
le stress est toujours présent à 3h30
pour faire de plat
après j'aurai un poulet à faire aussi
mais ça fait un petit peu tendancieux
pourquoi
parce que c'est propre 3h30 et puis
c'est pas forcément la maîtrise des
techniques de jeu utilise total onze
candidats concourent à l'épreuve de
cuisine et 11 autres en pâtisserie
fatoumata qui a choisi la pâtisserie
doit réaliser deux desserts dont une
tarte aux pommes mais elle a du mal à
s'organiser
j'avais déjà fait votre compost normé
encore vous avez foncé le phare note art
non d'accord à vous savez que les
preuves de la tarte
c'est un grand challenge pour moi de
finir dans les 3 4 me donnerais tout
pour l'objectif avant tout pour ses
candidats se former rapidement pour
pouvoir retrouver un emploi le but c'est
quand même de prendre des gens qui des
personnes comme je les dis qu'ils sont
là en reconversion
certains qui ont eu des parcours
difficiles il faut quand même le le
reconnaître et notre objectif c'est de
les redynamiser c'est de travailler avec
eux leur projet professionnel est
vraiment de leur réinsérer malgré le
stress celle yvelinois karim terbeche
qui a fini premier au concours de
cuisine fatoumata est arrivé troisième
en pâtisserie ils finiront tous les deux
leur ca fait en juin prochain